التقى وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن والوفد المرافق له مع الوفد
الاسرائيلي برئاسه وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي اسرائيل كاتس كان بلينكن قد
استهل مباحثاته في اسرائيل بلقاء اجراه مع
الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتسوغ صباح
اليوم حيث اشار الى انه سيطلع المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين على الاراء التي استمع اليها
من قاله دول زارها خلال جولته بشان
الاوضاع في غزه كان بلينكن قد قال قبل
وصوله انه سينقل الى المس الاسرائيليين ما
سمعه من قاده الدول التي زارها وانه
سيتحدث مع قاده اسرائيل بشان الاتجاه
المستقبلي لحملتهم العسكريه في غزه وعن
رؤيته لمستقبل المنطقه
واسرائيل للمتابعه معنا من رام الله مدير
مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري وليد ضعنا في
صوره او حيثيات المباحثات ما بين بلينكن
من طرف و الاسرائيليين من طرف
اخر مرشح بالاضافه لما ذكر في مقدمه هذا
الخبر هو ان بلينكن ايضا نقل لمن التقاهم
حتى الان من الاسرائيليين رساله بان باب
التطبيع مع عدد من الدول العربيه ما يزال
مفتوحا وان هذا الاحتمال سيتم تنفيذه
والعمل عليه بعد انتهاء هذه الحرب
الاجتماع الذي جرى وانتهى في هذه الدقائق
بين بلينكن والرئيس الاسرائيلي كان قد
تناول ثلاثه مواضيع تتعلق اولا
بقضيه مساله المحتجزين الاسرائيليين الذين
في قطاع غزه وعددهم نحو
136 وبلينك وعد الرئيس الاسرائيلي بالعمل
على تحريك المفاوضات من جديد وان هناك
جديه لدى الوسطاء للتحرك وكان ذووهم قد
تظاهروا امام فندق بلنسكي الذي جرى فيه
اللقاء بين بلينكن والرئيس الاسرائيلي
هيرتسوغ المووضوع الثاني الذي كان مفتوحا
هو ايضا ان هيرتسوغ حاول اقناع بلينكن بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعمل جدا على تجنيب
المدنيين في قطاع غزه من ويلات الحرب وقال
بان هناك فتحات لانفاق في منازلهم لذلك
يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي بقصفها والامر
الثالث الذي كان بينهما تعلق بمحكمه لاهاي
حيث انها ستنظر يوم الخميس والجمعه
بالالتماس الذي قدمه قدمته جنوب افريقيا
ويتهم اسرائيل بحرب اباده جماعيه للشعب
الفلسطيني وهناك كما يبدو موقف داعم
امريكي لاسرائيل في هذا الشان كي لا يتحول
الموضوع الى قضيه في مجلس الامن وضمان ان
تستخدم الولايات المتحده حق النقض الفيتو
لاسقاطه اذا صدر القرار بالفعل هذه الثلاث
قضايا التي كانت محور هذا اللقاء اللقاءات
الباقيه بين
بلينكن اهمها سيكون مع رئيس الحكومه
نتنياهو بعد قليل ومن ثم سيشارك في اجتماع
لمجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي وبعدها سيلتقي
وزير الدفاع جلنت ومن ثم وزير
الحرب الوزير في مجلس الحرب بين جانس زعيم
معسكر الدوله هذه الاجتماعات ستتناول
القضايا الاهم وهي اولا الطلب الامريكي
بضروره ان يكون هناك دخول اسرائيلي في الم
المرحله الثالثه على هيئه الانسحاب واعاده
الانتشار الى الحدود وابقاء داخل الحدود
ولكن مع اتاحه المجال امام المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الذين نزحوا قصرا من شمالي
القطاع الى جنوبه للعوده الى هذه المناطق
هذا موضوع خلافي بين الجانبين حتى الساعه
مضاعفه المساعدات الانسانيه والعمل على
ادخالها ايضا من منطقه معبر ايرز بيت حنون
لتصل الى المواطنين الفلسطينيه المنكوبين
في شمالي القطاع بالاضافه بالطبع لقضايا
اخرى تتعلق بالعمل على قضيه محاوله ايجاد
رؤيه سياسيه اسرائيليه لاداره قطاع غزه
بعد انتهاء الحرب او في اليوم التالي لهذه
الحرب المتواصله منذ
95 يوما هذه المواضيع فيها خلاف اسرائيلي
امريكي اسرائيل حتى الان لم تتخذ قرارا
واضحا بخصوص اليوم التالي للحرب وكيفيه
اليه اداره القطاع في حال انتهت هذه الحرب
كما تشتهي اسرائيل ثانيا لديها معارضه
شديده بان تلعب السلطه الفلسطينيه دورا في
اداره قطاع غزه حتى لو كان الى جانب تجمع
من عده دول عربيه واوربيه والقضيه الثالثه
بلينكن يريد من اسرائيل من الحكومه
الحاليه ان تحول عائدات الضرائب المعروفه
بالمقاصه المستح حقت عليها الى السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي تعاني من احتمال انهيار
اجهزتها بسبب عدم قدرتها على تسديد رواتب
موظفيها لقنص اسرائيل واقتناص
لهذه الاموال التي هي اصلا مستحقه
للفلسطينيين هذه الامور الاساسيه بالاضافه
لمحاوله العمل على نزع فتيل فجار حرب على
الجبهه مع لبنان المواضيع في مجملها
سيبحثها
بلينكن مع المسؤولين الاسرائيل وخاصه مع
مجلس الحرب وهذه هي المره الخامسه لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه التي يصل فيها الى
اسرائيل منذ بدايه الحرب ويشارك فيها
باجتماع كيف يبدو وضع نتنياهو ما بين
اليمين المتطرف
والتصريحات الاخيره للطرف الامريكي قبل
زياره بلينكن التي لم تكن وديه تجاه
اليمين المتطرف
الاسرائيل نعم نتنياهو يحاول المناوره هو
من ناحيه بحاجه لليمين المتطرف حليفه في
قاعدته الائتلافيه لهذه الحكومه لان
انسحابهم او اغضابه من شانه ان يسقط هذه
الحكومه فكان واضحا مواقف سموتريتش وبن
كفير بهذا الشان وهناك الموقف الامريكي
الذي المح لنتنياهو ومقربيه بان عليهم ان
يفكروا بين اختيارهم لليمين المتطرف
واختيارهم للتوجه الامريكي الداعم
لاسرائيل نتنياهو حتى الساعه ووفق كافه
المؤشرات في اسرائيل سواء كانت معارضه ام
مقربه منه ما يعنيه هو ان يكون ان يحافظ
على مكاسبه سياسيه حزبيه خاصه به لاطاله
امد حكومته قبل ان تنتهي هذه الحرب ويتعرض
للتحقيق على الفشل الذريع في فيها لذلك
هناك محاوله مناوره من جانب نتنياهو لكن
الاداره الامريكيه تضغط عليه بهذا الشان
وتخيره بين اما الاستمرار في حلفه مع
اليمين العنصري المتطرف ممثلا ببنك فير و
سموتريتش او ان يحاول ان يغير هذه الحكومه
وان يواصل على نحو يرضي الامريكيين وهنا
تلعب الورقه الاساسيه في هذه المعادله وهي
الرساله التي يحملها بلينكن وتسربت قبل
وصوله ان باب التطبيع ما يزال قائما وتقول
مصادر مقربه من نتنياهو انه من اجل تحقيق
ذلك وخاصه مع السعوديه فهو مستعد ان يتخذ
قرارات حاسمه ومفاجئه ومصير اذا تحقق فعلا
من ان التطبيع ممكن مع السعوديه وغيرها من
الدول العربيه الاخرى ولذلك هو ينتظر ان
يحصل على تاكيدات لان من شان تحقيق
التطبيع ان يعزز من شعبيته ويرممها من
جديد من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري شكرا جزيلا لك